i've always just tried to push myself to
see the world and explore
eventually
i found myself really concerned about
the fact that i was spending my time in
the outdoors without doing anything
beneficial for the world
i started an adventure scientist
believing that there would be thousands
of people like me who love the outdoors
and wish there was ways they could make
a difference
we are a non-profit organization based
in montana that mobilizes thousands of
people to go out and collect scientific
data for scientists who are using it to
solve massive societal issues if you can
imagine thousands of people who are out
hiking and skiing and biking and
climbing around the world collecting
scientific data that has been requested
by scientists that will help them solve
problems that's what we do at adventure
scientists
we've got about 8 000 people a month
coming to our website asking how they
can get involved and we built this
network by giving people in the outdoor
community a way that they could make a
difference with their time
we've collected the largest data set on
earth for micro plastics
we sent out volunteers all around the
world
to over 100 different countries to
collect scat samples we send these scats
back to the lab at harvard and this
brilliant research team has been able to
narrow the search for the genes
responsible for antibiotic resistance
down to less than 90 genes
[Music]
we've just hiked our way into the lolo
national forest this is right on the
edge of western red cedar's range and so
this is a super
exciting tree for us to core and get
some genetics out of
we're getting samples because as the
climate changes and adapts these trees
that are right on the fringes of the
habitat are likely to have genetics that
could really help us mitigate climate
change and the effects of climate change
on these tree species
and then the other reason is because we
want to create methods for the u.s fish
and wildlife service to
determine exactly where any piece of
wood came from and whether it was
legally or illegally harvested
when we are choosing projects the most
important to us is that there's going to
be a tangible pathway from data
collection to something being different
in the world
[Music]
the outdoors for me
makes me feel like there's some normalcy
in a very chaotic world
[Music]
to take my son out here and getting a
hike with him and show him this
incredible place it's amazing it just
means the world to me to be able to
expose him to this part that i love so
much
this is a gift and a privilege to have
this now and i'm not sure this will be
here forever
we need to empower scientists with every
single tool available on the planet to
make them successful because our entire
world and our entire livelihood depends
on it
[Music]